[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
calm down I know where you are hey there
well I'll be fine Mrs Madison how do you
know my name because you are one of my
guests
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
mr. Roy the plane it's here
[Applause]
[Music]
smiles everyone smiles
[Music]
oh this place doesn't suck
yo oh here let me give you an it was so
loud in there I'm Patrick I'm Gwen nice
to meet you welcome to Fantasy Island
and congratulations to each of you on
winning the contest this weekend you
will be our VIPs in return all we ask is
that you brag about us online when you
get home marketing 101 I'm Julia the
personal assistant to your host mr. Borg
yeah what's his story I couldn't begin
to tell you well I heard rocks family
bought this island from natives like 200
years ago but six cases of rum well I
heard that he was an angel investor in
the 90s got bored with Silicon Valley
and opened an amusement park trust me
the island is so much more here anything
and everything is possible
oh yes Oh guys high five a lot Oh mr.
work is making final preparations he
will meet you in the bar for an evening
drink in the meantime we will take you
through your rooms so you may change and
freshen up no service it's not
everything is possible
gentlemen I'll ask the two of you to
wait at the bar your quarters will be
ready shortly and the rest of you please
follow me you get the framing come on it
would be a dream baking without my baby
bro all right
Oh Bigham there's no need for money here
[Music]
[Music]
this is just for me what is called
Fantasy Island for a reason place where
anything and everything is possible you
said what you didn't say is how mister
work taylors AIT's fantasy specifically
to the guest based on a one-page
questionnaire I will confess I'm
relatively new here soon how mr. Rourke
does what he does is as much a mystery
to me as it is to you what I do know is
that your life is about to change
forever
apparently
[Music]
I will take two of those thank you
oh great I need a drink sorry I'm
double-fisting hmm can we talk to mr.
Roarke please we still have our room sir
hellooo hey man my brother's talking to
you that's me I'm hello you guys are
actually brothers oh you think because
we're different colors that means we
can't be brothers wow dude
racist much no I mean what do you mean
come on they don't like Asian people huh
why do you hate people it's not what I
said verbatim what you say you got a
racist haircut my dad married his mom
when this little dude was still in
pampers I'm JD you can call him t did
but we talked about this whatever
college to nickname Brax is fine Patrick
nice to meet you guys you boys can
always take Patrick's bungalow and he
can bungalow with me I'm Melanie I don't
think we had a chance to meet on the
plane but it was pretty noisy I can get
pretty noisy forward Melanie
you have no idea Patrick so what's your
fantasy oh that's a question for the
room I'm just curious how this all works
I was wondering that myself virtual
reality obviously maybe it's like LARP
live-action role-playing thanks a pretty
fun so I've heard from like dorks you
saved it thank you I bet you he's right
it's got to be some sort of immersive
experience what if your fantasy involves
a person from your life holograms
like Tupac what if it's somebody who
died Tupac well I saw in reddit that the
guy just pumps the drinks with tons of
hallucinogens crazy I promise
the only thing in those drinks is the
finest imported rum
good evening I am mr. work the
ambassador to your deepest desires let
me officially welcome you to Fantasy
Island
[Music]